das macht
moment mal ich habe eine woche kein
video gemacht
doch gar nicht so schlimm auch erst
einmal die woche ein video hochzuladen
aber woran dies ist dann hast du keine
idee
ich habe mindestens 100 ideen was man
zum beispiel kämpfst du bist du schauen
ja erklärt überlegt ihn zu ersten und
dabei noch etwas bewegen und dabei schäm
dich
die lobbys angesagt man sich nicht über
bios machen darf also schöne ja gut wenn
die leute das sagen hat doch einfach die
korrosion scream toto-pokal die danach
fragen wird schon seit einer ewigkeit da
würde ich ja gerne bis jetzt habe ich
nur die guten form und brauchen die
zutaten ja okay dann solltest du
vielleicht das gespräch darüber wie wir
nein nein wieso wege bitte dabei
zuschauen will mit dir selbst spricht
das hält niemand eigentlich länger als
eine minute aus als du warst mein handy
weg und geht brauchen danach genug
energie
ich glaub es nicht dass ich aus deiner
fantasie entsprungen
ja da musste ich mich schon viel mich
zusammenreißen das denn jetzt ja nicht
nur du bestimmt über das video doch ich
bin hier der chef
hey das ist mein nein nein
dann gehe ich jetzt wohin sie keine
ahnung des körpers noch nie fertig so
schnell könnte auch nicht schreiben
dann geht die in die küche und kümmert
sich um das mittagessen ich gehe jetzt
in die güte gottes mittagessen es gibt
pizza
es gibt pizza lasagne nein lasagne ok
fertig gutes video